mr. Leclerc you'll see the killed silica
in the hardener labate 'no Halina less
Omaha
four years ago no one could have
foreseen the tragedy Syria would soon
face the UN estimates that nearly 4
million people have fled since 2011 due
to the fighting since then 584 refugees
have been allowed to resettle in the
u.s. Lomonaco we visited one refugee
family in Sacramento and asked them to
share their story and recipes can apply
ethic of a lot of ask me about Hannah
malfini a bazooka hi-yah see turkey now
Shane come on
what oh one marvelous turtle is my
container sac nyan away
jozu body and Jose de Sola a lord on
stun hola Mahalo Oh hallelujah huh sorry
badly animus goofy channel occasionally
done cuz Pina ardena be only an official
mother in a little cost of the sugar
- Lala Josie animist ahead model anyone
big deal it's just Italian Josie is Omni
Lord own continent Elijah was a sofa le
lo la de la Edna a sheet and Nozomi
tomorrow to Arizona Rashad Cheadle
kathiyawadi Mbeki Morocco Lula Shakopee
MN ah her shitty low Paulo Selena not
lottery
lanai Oh Lord Anjaneya hey
Jana Corrie exist on the cell hamdullah
come on roll on the adjacent organ
inside no for what now
aw hiya Marty on Matt Hamill a ethnic
honestly I'm larvae short
Pamela an Intel halide mafia name
Hillel Asher died to flop the comment
give it the other yaha
I know same thing the Salafi no Han le
we under to receive all to live observer
I do like new to live surface as an
honorable fuckin a bad Mahabharata Wilma
laughs y'all are talking I'm alluding to
Matt the mother that American how to
serve it really handsome awesome
Clint with father low and Max Tokarski
Bella Darby look Alan Rica no yes I know
mother seven oh my mother's Terminator
don't ever look nervous Johnny come
Hamid I know the unofficial relationship
yeshua overseer wound up in the surah
nisa boxer e7 Brock Lesnar America's
Stevenson other dr. Bennett lashing it
doesn't doesn't air any Serena dbi
symbol given Muhammadiyah burger
Ginobili with Turkey I will be Lebanon
Lotus ah ba ba yan Ashoka hotel hockey I
mean I'd mahaki Nicole any member to the
world with you follow after my number
talk a nursery Erica Sylvia madam
tatianna
and how does a submit well at nights of
it might be a lot better we had a little
lamb gyro Hampton Holland Michigan
yeah she's a little below really
celibate ended Roger had an island
garage its Moody has our America and I
know well for my under Vesuvius jaja
blood now Willie
JJ he's awfully makin America to smuggle
food to my mother mother Cochran yoga
and Stabbin shifted Amarone Mustapha
name's Devin do mr. Brad namaste banana
hat are universal
I'm sure lagna have a higher blood
numbers no Tyler Malone in shell of a
cero her name was yet the blood now no
John sha Allah mama wants to degrade and
destroy the Islamic state and now the
United States is set to train and fund
the select group of Syrian rebels to do
just that